- Your son is a teenager
now, right?
- Yeah.
- We have teenagers, so go ahead.
- I think he's havin' sex now.
(laughter)
He hasn't admitted to me.
- Wait.
- But I think he's
havin' sex now.
- What is the tell-tale there?
- Because he just got
cool all of a sudden.
(laughter)
(applause)
There's somethin' about sex
that just smooth you right out, you know?
- I would have disagreed
until I saw "40 Year Old Virgin."
And I'm like, "Maybe."
- No, no, no, no, no.
He used to be a nerd.
He used to be like, "Hey, dad!
"Let's go get some pizza!"
And then one day, I went on a role
for two weeks and came back.
I was like, "Let's go get some pizza,"
and he was like, "Why don't
you bring me back a slice?"
(laughter)
(claps)
- [Kelly] First of all.
- "What you get all cool for?
"You havin' sex?
"I think you havin' sex."
(laughs)
(claps)
- I am gonna die when that happens.
- Oh, you gonna die!
- Die!
- I'm gonna be like,
"No, la, la, la, la, la!"